welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Star Wars Episode nine the
rise of Skywalker is a couple months
away meaning we have until December
until our lightsabers get confiscated by
the movie theater ushers but one mystery
that the rise of Skywalker will finally
clear up for us is the question of the
Knights of Ren or Nate to Brin first
introduced in Ray's force dream in the
force awakens the Knights of Ren are
kylo Ren's gang of followers about whom
we learned little more since the last
Jedi director Rian Johnson let them out
of episode 8 he remarked that the red
clad praetorian guard were originally
going to be the Knights of Ren thus why
both groups cover their faces and masks
and carry a variety of melee weapons but
Johnson intended on killing that group
off and JJ Abrams had some greater
significance to the Knights of Ren left
to explore and we now are finally
getting a clearer picture of what that
significance is join me as I explain
everything we know about the Knights of
Ren Euler warning in case this
explanation is just too much for you ok
before ray saw a flash of the Knights of
Ren in her forced dream the group was
mentioned by name by then Supreme Leader
Snoke who credited kylo Ren as the
master of that group even you must hold
the Knights of Ren have never faced such
a test they had been described in
supporting text as force-sensitive
practitioners of the dark side but that
they are neither Jedi nor sethe while
they did not appear in the last Jedi
Luke Skywalker did say a line that some
consider a nod to their origin
when discussing Ben solos violent
departure from his training temples
burning he'd vanished with a handful of
my students who slaughtered the rest
that handful of students might have used
their powers for evil like a gang of
high school dropouts using their
chemistry knowledge to cook meth but
speaking of crystal this raises a
question why is kylo the only member of
this groups use a lightsaber with a
Kyber crystal that we have learned is
fractured we do know for the flashback
in the last Jedi that Jedi students use
lightsabers but the other Knights of Ren
use a variety of melee weapons like
vibro X's cool perhaps has the most
advanced of luke students only kylo
possesses the ability to build his own
lightsaber or as the leader of this gang
he allows only himself the right to
wield a lightsaber kind of like in my
childhood gang only I was able to use to
slingshot the other kid
to use arrow heads like a bunch of
losers just kidding when I was a kid and
the only members of my gang were
imaginary recently the book the ultimate
Star Wars a new edition describes the
Knights of Ren with this deeper insight
the Knights of Ren are kylo Ren's most
deadly and mysterious servants with
their bodies and Kayson rusty battered
armor their face is permanently
concealed beneath ominous masks echoing
that of the new supreme leader himself
even their species remains a mystery
what it's obvious to anyone who
witnesses them in action is that their
fighting skills and martial prowess are
without equal each Knight is armed with
a lethally effective and unique weapon
suited to either long-range or close
quarter combat hmm that sounded cool
this tells us that we may never see
underneath their masks and helmets they
could be a variety of alien species that
never get identified and along with this
description we also saw a set photo of
some Knights of Ren up close a caption
that described them as masked the
Warriors with specialized weaponry who
had an element of chaos to the war
between the resistance in the first
order based on that background there
that location appears to be the new
desert planets personna
home to the akiaki tribe who's shown up
in trailer footage but for what they
drew a gender the Knights of Ren might
be it could help to look back at some of
the Star Wars novels that have helped
fill in the historical gaps before
between and after these events
specifically chuck wendig's fantastic
aftermath series I listen to wind eggs
aftermath and audiobook form on audible
thank you to audible for sponsoring this
episode by the way audible has the
world's largest selection of audio books
and audio entertainment including
audible originals stories created
exclusively for audio including
documentaries exclusive audio books and
scripted shows that you can't hear
anywhere else
audible offers a convenient audible app
where you can listen on any device while
doing anything cooking working out
sitting in your car and your apartment
garage weirding out your neighbors
because you cannot move until the battle
of jakku is over audible members can
choose one audio book every month where
guard lists of price as well as two
audible originals from a fresh selection
and members can keep their library of
listens for live birth and can easily
exchange any title at any time start
listening with a thirty-day audible
trial in your first audiobook plus two
audible originals for free that audio
book could be chuck wendig's aftermath I
highly recommend it just go to
audible.com slash new rockstars again
audible.com
slash new rock stars AUD IB le carré
slash any WRs EK s VAR s or text the
word new rock stars - 500 500 but back
to Wai aftermath could be so important
to the origin of the Knights of Ren
aftermath introduces a group called the
acolytes of the beyond acolytes are sith
worshippers who are obsessed with
collecting since artifacts including
Darth Vader's lightsaber they were
active in the years shortly after the
Battle of Endor long before the first
order rose to prominence circa the force
awakens wind again as another prelude
story coming out about the rise of kylo
Ren that could likely explore the origin
of the Knights of Ren but until that
comes out on December 18th one popular
theory is that the acolytes of the
beyond either inspired the Knights of
Ren or literally became that group
itself with Ben solo perhaps I'll stay
in their previous leader to become kylo
Ren and then using that status to gain
the attention of Snoke and then later
replacing Snoke as supreme leader of the
first order because this new description
of the Knights of Ren singles out their
masks which were made in the image of
kylo ren's mask a mask that he modeled
on the mask of his grandfather Darth
Vader remember kylo actually possesses
the burnt remains of Vader's mask
implying he could have looted his
grandfather's grave the jedi funeral
pyre on Endor similarly the other
Knights of Ren could also have formed
their helmets and armor from other
scavenged pieces of Darth Vader's
damaged armor which could be why their
armor is described as rusty and battered
they could have peeled this off the
charred skeleton of kylos grandpappy one
of the prominent locations in the rise
of skywalker appears to be the ruins of
the second Death Star a place where both
ray and kylo appear since that Death
Star was destroyed adjacent to endure in
return the jedi that could establish
that setting as Endor where Vader's
remains would be nearby and this
backstory of the Knights of Ren as Jedi
dropouts turned grave-robbing cult could
be revealed and described as a separate
group of warriors who add even more
chaos to the war between the resistance
in the first order I believe Kyla's old
gang could return to challenge their old
master for using them as mere stepping
stones to higher ambitions and demand he
reconnect the spiritual roots of their
cause a strict devotion to the memory of
his rogue grandfather what do you think
is the origin of the Knights of Ren
comment down below with your thoughts
and to help free me from this temporary
blue dungeon into a new home to help us
go even deeper into Star Wars theory and
analysis please consider becoming a
patron of new rock stars Digital Studios
you nerds patrons can get early access
to certain videos and an exclusive
monthly breakdown for details just check
out the link in the description below
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
loss thank you for joining me and if my
theory is right which Knight of Rin do
you think got stuck with Vader's armored
Cup be like Joey ran can we just a
trade-off wearing Vader's gauntlet this
is a this thing just feels wrong
[Music]